[Music]
what did you think of the winners did
you enjoy were you happy about people
that won
I was I was psyched about spotlight that
was that was really cool yeah it was a
great night yeah when well did you like
the revenant did you like that that
movie yeah I think that movie is like
kind of like a you know force of nature
it's undeniable I did have kind of a
funny experience when I was watching it
though and it kept building and the
thought was like what else can they do
to this dude I mean if you think about
the revenant is basically like a
dramatic version of weekend at Bernie's
where like like a prio semi lifeless
body through like a series of ridiculous
situation right right right
I was imagining like the pitch the pitch
for the script was like okay we'll push
it up a hill we'll roll it down drop it
in a river and it'll go through some
Rapids and like slam into some rocks and
then some other dudes like no no no no
let's blast it with an old-timey shotgun
and then leave it there and then a
grizzly bear will come and play with it
like it's a whoopee cushion right third
guy's like no no no we're gonna put it
on a horse running full speed and a
bunch of Native Americans gonna shoot
arrows at it and then it's gonna drop
off a cliff into a pine tree and smash
down and so basically I was think I was
like this guy's a brilliant director but
he's also kind of like a nine-year-old
boy with like a two hundred million
dollar budget it's the stuff I used to
do with my GI Joe know it's like I used
to tie it I used to climb up on top of a
building that was near us and I would hi
my GI Joe to wood truck and throw it off
put it there with many things as
possible yeah I was friends with a guy
who did it with the lizard it was super
sad oh yeah did it look a living thing
yes the profile of a serial killer I
believe so how's he doing um I think
he's still living in his mom's basement
actually they should dig up that
basement they should
just saying check out the basement
[Applause]
you